boy they're all good he has so many
winners what would you say ted is your
your favorite of you my favorite one is
the elephant and the dog story
remember that one i think i might have
sent it to you
check it out for yourself the elephant
can dog become good friends and the rest
is history i'm gonna google that and
watch you gotta watch it grab some
tissues too okay you're gonna you're
gonna need it for that you know we get
some over here we got you covered it's
all good
i might need it for the pollen and
everything in the wind
i'll sneeze later we'll do that he's
going to delay
delay
that tells you how much sneezing we've
been doing here this spring time right
live look outside so see the camera
moving there in that wind so we have
those winds again picking up again but
the stronger winds come tomorrow that's
a strat cam looking to the north towards
the sheep range 87 degrees our official
high for the day today 60 for the
overnight low above average for our
temperatures the record on the state
look at this 107 back in 1947 air
conditioning was horrible back then
currently outside 85 in centenni hills
81 in summerlin and 84 for the lakes 86
downtown the east side typically warmer
89 for you sunrise manor 88 double
eights for you in green valley 84 roads
ranch mountains edge and spanish trails
88 right now for henderson we love
eight's here on channel 80 for indian
springs 99 look at that death valley at
99 degrees 87 for boulder city at this
hour our radar network sweeping around
not picking up any shower activity here
unfortunately but to find that you've
got to go way up to the pacific
northwest again i didn't put that low
icon on there to show you because i
wanted to show you the actual low and
its spin in the atmosphere and that's
what we're seeing right now this is
going to dive down to the southeast but
we'll see a cold front pass through the
region tonight and tomorrow so if you
plan to do some golf tomorrow a lot of
people texting me about golf tomorrow
not a good day for that okay forget
about it the reason for that is because
of this we do have those strong winds
that we're anticipating for tomorrow
specifically in the morning hours even
though we don't have any wind advisories
issued yet we do expect the stronger
winds in the morning 81 degrees will be
high for tomorrow the other big story of
course are the warmer temperatures we're
going to see this week the warmest
temperature of the year so far was 93
degrees on march 26th we're going to
exceed that on thursday and friday look
at these numbers here
luckily though we're not going to reach
those records that were set back are
actually triple digit records so we'll
come close to them but not going to
reach them and then look at this
temperature drop by the time we get to
mother's day from 96 friday to 79 on
mother's day evening planner notice your
wind speeds right here still remaining
breezy for tonight 82 degrees at 9 p.m
breezy winds 8 news 9 11 76 but notice
breezy winds still and we're going to
have gusty winds tomorrow morning for
all so keep that in mind your high
tomorrow will be only 81 degrees wind
tomorrow look at the temperatures
warming up and then cooling off like we
said for mother's day remember that if
you're making big plans and then staying
cool also next week that's your most
accurate weather update we'll send it
over to ron and derrick england
all right teddy terrific fine job there
we got good weather here in the valley
that's sort of nice okay